E aí
[Música]
é bem eu sou o professor da Universidade
Federal de Alagoas Eu tenho 46 anos por
amor a matemática EA física eu escolhi a
30 anos fazer engenharia e seguir ia uma
carreira acadêmica padrão no Brasil
conheço eu fiz mestrado e doutorado na
PUC do Rio e a partir daí eu me dediquei
e me dedico ainda hoje a simulação
computacional de programas relacionados
ao setor de petróleo gás e energia e em
2001 em 1999 eu tive que voltar Alagoas
e voltando Alagoas em 2001 eu acabei me
tornando professor da universidade e
junto com alguns parceiros da vida né E
nós construímos esses caras que estão aí
nós construímos juntos um laboratório
que é um dos maiores Laboratórios
computacionais do Brasil aqui em Alagoas
Olá aqui é o Mc CV ele e esse
laboratório além da estrutura e da nossa
alma da alma de 100 pesquisadores tem
também um super computador e esse super
computador ele tem a capacidade de 20
pela flop e ele a época era o terceiro
maior supercomputador da América Latina
e foi com ele que nós fizemos algumas
simulações computacionais do processo de
perfuração dos primeiros Poços do
pré-sal né Então essa turma que tá aí
junta junto com a nossa mão empresa de
petróleo do Brasil e uma das melhores do
mundo a Petrobras a gente se orgulha
muito de em 10 anos menos de dez anos a
descoberta do pré-sal a gente ter
contribuído e chegado a produção de um
milhão de Barris por dia enfim
bom então essa história é naturalmente
que a inauguração de um laboratório
desse forte no estado pequena como
Alagoas e é gerar uma movimentação na
cidade e aí é Na inauguração a presença
de autoridades Governador Deputado enfim
outras personalidades locais e nacionais
e ouvir a oração no dia seguinte nem me
deu aquele eu fui para casa e me deu
aquele aquele vazio S acho que meio tipo
depressão pós-parto assim É como se eu
tivesse cumprido uma parte da minha da
minha missão como professor na UFAL é só
que não tinha essa depressão dia
seguinte tinha que acordar aí e para o
trabalho e aí vamos embora e a partir
daí né aconteceu que vários colegas meus
amigos começaram me mandar sms dizendo
ao Governador tá falando
o laboratório aqui né assim para mim
aquilo é uma coisa tão distante que eu
simplesmente via achava interessante ali
mas minimizava aí seguia né então quando
foi praticamente um ano depois da
inauguração a inauguração foi em
novembro aí em outubro a reitora da
Universidade me faz uma ligação dizendo
que tinha recebido um telefonema do
Palácio tão vendo e que eu teria que ir
com ela para uma reunião com o grupo com
um cara do Conselho de administração do
grupo de Eike Batista
ó e aqui assim me assustou um pouco né
Eu disse vamos embora então com 18 anos
de Universidade a gente tinha construído
um dos maiores laboratórios de
computação no Brasil eu pensei o
precisar na situação que estava todo
mundo acreditando em tudo em oito anos a
gente fez um laboratório
em uma reunião com um membro do Conselho
de administração de um dos caras mais
ricos e promissores do Brasil daqui a 8
anos ou é mai pin em Alagoas e
e o embate seria aqui e aí é eu preparei
tudo que tinha que preparar folder BVB
tudo que fosse necessário para convencer
o cidadão de investimento aqui não tinha
outro caminhão e aí marcamos né
embarcamos Eu e a reitora rumo essa
viagem e aí foi para o rio a gente
chegou na noite do dia anterior à
reunião era só no outro dia tarde
naturalmente que eu nervosismo né a
reitora mais sobra claro né é a reitora
e eu naquela ansiedade é E aí nós uma
hora marcada nós fomos para o escritório
local da reunião e chegando na reunião
eu esperava
eu ir para ir para o x que a empresa
maior do jeito de leite Batista e eu
imaginei um prédio assim hi-tech né
tempo esse que vai levar mostrou aqui de
Abu Dhabi E aí quando eu chego na rua a
rua é essa e o prédio é esse
E aí eu imaginei É um trote na reitora e
do professor
é mas Subimos o elevador daqueles né
daqueles assim antigo Subimos entram em
uma sala né e entramos numa sala na
verdade a falar com ela Não era essa é
uma outra sala se cinematográfica pela
atividade se o negócio realmente
maravilhoso e olhava para reitor assim
ela ri um pouco e não entendia nem acho
que vem da minha angústia né E aí nós
vamos chamado para essa sala e nessa
sala é nós encontramos eu me deparei aí
com o doutor Raphael de Almeida
Magalhães ele não está mais aqui entre
nós Mas eu já tinha pesquisado na
internet quem era o sujeito que eu ia me
encontrar né para saber se ele ia fazer
em mente
Oi e aí é boa para o Rafael ele tinha
ele já tinha sido o governador do Estado
da Guanabara ele já tinha sido ministro
da presidência enfim ele tinha uma ação
é importante do país e junto com ele na
mesma reunião nessa sala Carlos monte né
que é amigo dele e hoje é amigo pessoal
meu e pai da Marisa Monte que eu tava no
show dela antes de ontem ou seja se eu
saísse em contrato eu já tenho conhecido
pelo menos o padre Marisa Monte A
Oi e aí né nossa conversa começou Doutor
Rafael começa a contar a história do
Estado de Alagoas os problemas sociais
econômicos e políticos a partir de 1957
Essa foi a primeira colocação dele ou
seja 1997 para quem não sabe é o ano que
a gente fez o Hipismo em um governador e
pela tepco na assembleia e pra ele saiu
e aí ele começou a contar os problemas
sociais do Estado de Alagoas e
convenhamos penso né
Oi e aí chegou na hora da reunião que eu
tinha certeza que não era um toque mas
eu tinha certeza também que não era para
eu tá lá eu imaginava não eu sou
professor
a corretora ela assim né porque ela é
reitora na minha cabeça naquela naquele
momento ela tinha uma das Missões dela
seria atuar para resolver o problema do
Estado viu com um supercomputador de 20
ter a própria em Alagoas
o que queria fazer filho a reunião se
ferrou depois de 3 horas ouvindo a
história de Alagoas assim eu não conheci
nada
Oi e aí é encerrou e ele passou uma
missão para mim pela reitora ainda mais
ainda mais essa ele saiu um trabalho né
E aí ele disse olhar eu quero que vocês
em 20 dias levanta e com os professores
da universidade é uma penca de solução
dos problemas sociais de Alagoas
em Star
E aí pô conversa com ele aí a reunião
sem Senhor Inclusive a reitora ela ela
num determinado momento da conversa ela
interrompeu eu tô Rafael com muita
educação não precisa infinito ela é e
começou a explicar quem eu era
e olha o professor é um pesquisador
trabalha com setor de petróleo dando a
entender que eu vivo a buscar um
contrato não foi para começar seu
negócio e aí só que essa altura meu fo
DVD não fazia mais melhor sentido e aí
quando ela interrompeu que o Rafael olha
para mim começou é quantas pessoas
trabalham aí eu ia dizer agora né
de 100 pessoas
só pelo Face
os professores não muda nada
é uma realidade do Estado
e ele gostou e aí ele volta volta para
mim rapaz vocês estão uns sem os 100
trabalhando para o Sudeste
é o preço é no sudeste vocês estão lá
fazendo isso Professor pense nos do
Flamengo do Estado eu é do casamento
eu estou
E aí
e ele ainda chegou a dizer no final né
ele disse ó se quiser algum projeto
algum projeto de pesquisa de engenharia
amanhã vocês vão na loja x e conversa lá
com flor em metal
a essa hora não queria mais nada né Eu
queria voltar pra casa a reunião fomos
pro aeroporto eu provocado
tô conversando com a reitora chegou no
aeroporto eu imediatamente para livraria
tentando entender o que tinha acontecido
e aí eu fui pra prateleira o negócio da
livraria E aí eu sair eu tirei esse
livro é
é porque eu pensei negócio social
e era o que tinha era um que tinha feito
É isso aí eu peguei conheci nesse
momento no remédio uns Prêmio Nobel da
Paz
eu abri no avião eu abro
a primeira página e leia o seguinte a
o meu envolvimento com problemas da
pobreza ocorreu quando eu era acadêmico
em seguida fui levado por um episódio
pessoal quase por acaso envolvido com a
pobreza porque ela me cercava por todo
lado em Bangladesh em particular a fome
generalizada de 74 empurrou-me para fora
do campus universitário e funciona ser
uma ativista social além de professor na
outra passagem fui achando cada vez mais
difícil conservar ensinando elegante
teorias econômicas da sala de aula
enquanto lá fora grassava uma fome
pavorosas fechei o livro sentimento de
culpa Master
a empatia Total o nome é de uns e sair
dali pensando que eu pensei será que
ainda dá tempo de fazer alguma coisa e
desmarca em Alagoas e fica pensando pela
primeira vez eu comecei a pensar em
alguma coisa para Alagoas e
Oi e aí no dia vinte e oito de dezembro
é eu voltando de uma reunião no rio napa
trollagem me liga o governador
há 10 horas da noite eu achei que eu
tinha feito alguma coisa né
já começou aqui o governador eu tô lhe
convidando para ser secretário
e a partir de 1º secretário de Ciência
Tecnologia e inovação eu você
pessoalmente trocado não tem nada enfim
não sei o seguinte no dia dois eu tava
entrando na secretaria eu meu filho esse
Limpo
é porque eu tinha certeza que missão a
parte da Lei era ela era muito mais
social do que científica e tecnológica e
foi e no governo né eu conhece a Bíblia
de 40 anos trabalhei quatro anos
incansavelmente todos os dias e aí
milhares de histórias né diversos não é
como como vocês estão vendo aí né É
muita coisa bacana né história engraçada
por isso que fim de tudo aconteceu na
intensidade eo volume de trabalho só que
duas coisas me marcaram muito né nessa
nessa nessa jornada A primeira foi um
equipamento de chamado Telecentro que
mostrou ao cientista
e o valor de 10 computadores simples
conectado à Internet numa sala com
ar-condicionado em regiões de extrema
pobreza pobreza foram 60 dessa 60 desses
inclusive alguns na rua lateral da UFAL
e enfim
e não era um negócio mas era social eu
já estava a cada visita que fazia
aumentava a emoção aumentava EA dívida
diminuir
Oi e aí o outro caso né um caso desses
três alagoanos que eles foram um pingo
de Matos para mim e muita relação com
essa atenção aí do Social
é o seguinte quando eu participei desse
evento primeiro DeMolay da história do
Estado de Alagoas é um evento Startup
fiz a palestra Quando cheguei em casa e
noite ouve esses três caras aí tem um
Grande Prémio aplicativo aí cruzamos um
para incluir socialmente as pessoas
imediatamente em imediatamente quando eu
vi na internet e eu vi o que era eu fiz
a conexão com o livro
e eu tava diante
eu vi um negócio social em Alagoas eu
disse agora então daí em diante o que eu
pudesse fazer como cidadão secretário
para esse negócio dá certo eu faria e aí
é hoje eles são os grandes puxadores
assim dos urubus um vale que tem tem uma
repercussão hoje nacional e aí através
deles desses três jovens e de um
aplicativo eu realizei uma parte do meu
sonho a dois meses é Ronaldo Tenório
para ganho mais recebendo um prêmio como
um dos 35 maior mais inovadores jovens
do mundo primeiro brasileiro a receber
esse prêmio não é mais o empate ainda
não é Alagoas mais um pedacinho de nós
tava lá
Oi e aí tem ninguém 2015 meu querido
amigo Carlos wanderlan pelo WhatsApp
Manda essa foto
e quando ele mandou essa foto postou no
Facebook eu disse estava feita conexão
e o indiano que escreveu o livro que me
inspirou tava conhecendo o aplicativo
que a gente sonhou junto com a panela
enfim
Quem é E aí
e nessa jornada é o que eu pude perceber
foi quê
e a partir de uma conversa e de um livro
é um pedacinho da minha missão mais
social no terceiro física e tecnológica
estava Comprida
G1
o que eu acho isso Nada paga esse
sentimento
bom e foi assim que eu aprendi o
verdadeiro valor de uma provocação Boa
noite filha te dá um nojo e